i am dicarlo mckeithen i am the owner
here uh at kay's kitchen when i found
this space i thought it would be the
perfect location for delhi i came to
vegas last year for my birthday and i
just thought this would be a really good
location i decided to do a small takeout
restaurant my wife has always wanted to
cook so
i decided to do a small take out
american style restaurant there's
challenges with everything right there's
the scene the known in the unknown
and our biggest was was the unknown you
don't know what's behind the walls or on
the roof two fridays ago on the 30th
someone decided to run into the front of
the store my cameras captured it it was
a red toyota pickup truck he entered a
parking lot uh and and as soon as he
exited he came right back in
the exit and ran into my my front glass
he did not stop uh leave any information
so i could really use the community's
help and trying to track this guy down
the difficulty has been
as far as construction is getting
reliable contractors good licensed
contractors so you can find a lot of
people that want to work right but you
can't find uh the licensed contractors
um that were able to do the work inside
of the pandemic so it definitely
prolonged things even
now with uh just trying to get the
window replaced i call
i believe four different window people
and i've only heard from one and that's
been pretty consistent plumbers same
thing electrician same thing so you know
you have a time frame that you're trying
to get things done